well if you're ready to jet set away for
the summer there are some things to keep
in mind as you start booking your travel
so joining us with some helpful tips is
gabe saglier from travel zoo gabe thanks
for being here
thanks i love your tie it just screams
summer it is it's a summer time perfect
let's jump right into it we're all
traveling we're packing our bags flights
and airports are a little crazy right
now my very first question is to you is
i've been hearing to book the first
flight out because of all these
cancellations is that something you
recommend doing starting like a business
traveler nobody likes that alarm going
off at 3 30 in the morning but those
first flights out of the day those have
the best on time performance even if the
fight was super late the night before
that aircraft is there and odds are that
that crew is fresh and ready ready to
roll if there are any problems you've
got the entire day to deal with them
versus these 4 5 6 p.m flights where
sometimes that window of opportunity is
very very slim so
wake up early that first flight out will
probably you know avoid a lot of
headaches for you yeah it'll be worth it
and you guys have kind of put together
this a survival guide and that's one of
the tips that you recommend doing what
else do you suggest to people as they're
booking their summers right stay
flexible tuesdays and saturdays are
lower demand days and a lot of business
folks travel on a monday if we're going
out on for the weekend we're flying out
friday so tuesdays and saturdays there
are there's just less demand and
therefore just better odds that
cancellations and delays won't happen as
readily don't connect uh yes sometimes
that one or two stop flight is going to
be cheaper but think of that non-stop
flight as an investment in just sanity
uh i mean keep in mind we're seeing
we've seen more delays and cancellations
so far this year than all of 2021 so
this is a reality that stays with
through the summer avoiding connections
simply makes uh makes a lot of sense
don't check any bags which i know sounds
a lot uh easier uh you know said than
done uh but yeah i'm going to my with my
wife and three kids to hawaii in about a
week and a half and i've already told
them no checking bags everything fits in
that backpack and that little carry-on
that's all you need to get out there
again bags being put through the system
we're already seeing a bump up in lost
and delayed luggage out there uh so just
avoid it by not checking any bags then
there's something called hub to hub
flights if you're going to a certain
destination look at the airline that's
hubbed there so if it's san francisco
for example that's united if it's
atlanta that might be a delta uh the
fact is that because we're to look
talking about hub destinations more
aircraft and more crews to to you know
deal with if there are delays and
cancellations they're not guarantees but
something to keep in mind yeah all
really helpful tips and we were just
talking about hawaii obviously everyone
is excited about tropical destination so
what are some of the hot spots or places
you do recommend visiting for the summer
so we've seen even during the pandemic a
lot of these tropical destinations uh
were waiving a lot of these requirements
so let's look at the dominican republic
always a top five caribbean destination
out there lots of flights lots of
resorts on the grounds that competition
generates some nice uh value this is a
place called the margaritaville island
reserve in punta cana on the easternmost
shores of the dominican republic so
brand new property five stars 11
restaurants multiple pools they've got a
brewery on site so you don't have to go
anywhere uh and it's an all-inclusive uh
price point here it's 378 to 398 per
couple per night but again that's
all-inclusive you get a 500 resort
created as well for those massages that
you've got to have on the beach when
you're there well you can't be any of
that so what you're saying is pack a
carry-on and head to the dominican
republic so gabe thank you for the tips
enjoy hawaii and we'll see you next time
all right las vegas now we'll be right
back